[Music]  you know hi Peter I haven't heard from  you in a while so I thought I'd give you  a call that's it  I love you it's your mother just goes by  in a flash I know tell me the same thing  every 10 years come here a lot  yes no not a lot I mean sometimes what's  your name Gloria are you asking me out  out out a lot more of the sights  not a little bit more than that  [Music]  she will water I'd be a glass to her  foot I'd be a sock  can't get you out of my head  I happen to be with you I thought it was  never gonna happen again  happy birthday sweetheart that's my  ex-husband  what's in an easy situation really I  searched for your eyes I didn't exist  [Music]  this woman is awesome free her right  respect her  it cost me every five minutes don't pick  it up  [Music]  yeah oh my god my name is KY could die  tomorrow we could all die tomorrow  well when the world blows up hope I go  down dancing  [Music]